[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now this is
awesome getaway driver is a new reality
competition series on
discovery it is in real life fast and
furious that's the best way to describe
it it's actually hosted by michelle
rodriguez from the movie franchise
and tonight we have a local contestant
on the show michelle abate welcome to
the show
thank you so much thanks for having me
okay first off how would you describe
getaway driver
it's pretty much like a hot pursuit you
know you've got money in your car and
you're trying to escape
and hopefully they don't catch you or
take you out i was watching the first
couple episodes you're a professional
race car driver
okay how did you get on the show first
off well they actually reached out to me
on my social media so
it was just random and you're kind of
like is this real you know what i mean
and
it was just kind of shot off from there
now talk to me about the car
this is the car you actually use on the
show tell me more about the car
yeah so it's a 2006 subaru wrx it's a
turbo car
and we pretty much prepped it uh girl
racing is my race team
and we prepped this car for the show we
raised it one half inch lift kit from
settle solutions
we've got rally tires from federal and a
full roll cage inside of it we've got
recaro race seats and a bunch of
mishimoto stuff under the hood we really
soup this thing up so tonight is your
episode and watching the first couple
episodes
so you're you're in this compound it's a
60 acre compound
you get in your car michelle rodriguez
drops like a couple thousand dollars and
says go your objective is to escape the
compound
how do you train for something like this
when you have three cars chasing after
you how do you train for this
well i kind of treated it like a race
and in a race you can't predict what's
going to happen you just kind of have to
react and be smart smart
stay cool you know be smooth and so
pretty much just rely on your instincts
and your reaction and that's what i did
and
i'm so pumped for you guys to see it
tonight because it was a ton of fun it's
going to be so awesome but but they're
playing for real they're
smashing into your car they're trying to
take you out do you get refunded for any
damages
oh no not at all unless you make it
through the gate that's the only chance
you get to take any money home so
no it's kind of all on you as a driver
not to mess up can i sit inside the car
and this is this is just a super it was
what this is yes
okay turbo keys in if you want to start
it out oh i'll start it up here
but tell me you have some special
switches that helps you out on the show
what are the switches i do i have a
ghost mode which is on the on the dash
there and when you push ghost mode all
the back
lights on your car shut off they can't
see you and then i've got a front
bar um that has rally lights from diode
dynamics so they're like
super bright and we tossed one in the
back too but i wasn't allowed to use the
backpack
anything about that's great you're being
chased you hit the switch all of a
sudden these bright lights go after the
person that's chasing you
and also dark mode because you guys do
compete at night as well they can't find
you
yeah exactly so that was the point was
to try that out so yep grab that key
and then you're gonna put in the
ignition over there key in the ignition
make sure your
neutral you should be good there you go
oh yeah yeah so oh
yeah now michelle rodriguez from fast
and furious is the host did you watch
fast and furious
i've seen the first one but i haven't
seen any after that
no i i gotta wrap it up for about 30
seconds you're doing a viewing party
tonight where's the viewing party yeah
twin peaks on eastern so come down come
hang out check the car out we'll be down
there so
come check it out and then you go on
instagram live to ask questions right
answer questions afterwards i'll be on
my instagram live after that which you
can find on my fender
follow me on instagram we do it for the
gram michelle i love this your car is
awesome las vegas is going to be rooting
for you you're unlv
grad we love that you're from las vegas
you're going to represent on the show
and i got a feeling you're going to go
far in this competition
thank you so much check it out guys uh
mercedes i'm going to send it back to
you if you want to get on the other side
we'll get some coffee or something
all right back to you mercedes